We wanted to do a "Firefly" reunion in honor,
of by the way,
all of us women out there who are missing our girlfriends,
"Firefly" is such an amazing celebration
of female friendship,
and I was obsessed with the actress who plays you
as the teenage version of Sarah's character.
And we invite her here, please welcome Roan Curtis.
(audience applauds)
Hi.
Roan I'm so excited to meet you.
I was obsessed with you, watching the show.
That is the biggest compliment,
I'm so excited to be here.
I was obsessed with you both,
you both two people make one whole person,
and your character, Kate,
you guys learned mannerisms together and practiced together,
is that true?
Yeah.
I mean, it's funny, I grew up watching "Scrubs"
and so for me at least like we work together,
but for me I feel like kind of understanding
Sarah and her mannerisms was quite easy for me
because I spent so much of my life watching her.
That is helpful.
And you guys are so similar on screen
but I wanted to see
what both of you guys are like offscreen
since I'm such an uberfan of you on screen,
and I was wondering if you guys would play a game with me
called "Face the Fun Facts".
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
Okay, here's how it works.
A fact is going to go up on the screen and appear
and I've never seen these fun facts,
so I'm going to guess if the fun fact
is about Sarah or Roan
and the person who it's about will reveal herself
and explain the fact.
Sounds great.
Okay, let's see the first fact.
Kicked out of the choir in the fifth grade.
I think it was Sarah.
You would be correct it was Mrs McKinnon,
Ah, sorry.
And it was basically singing Christmas carols in a mall,
not a fancy choir
and Mrs. McKinnon said, Chalke girls
so she lumped in my sister and I together,
could you just mouth the words for this performance?
(audience laughing)
I love that.
I love that story.
Perfect visual.
Okay the next one,
wore matching outfits with mom on Mother's Day.
I'm going with Roan on this one.
You would be correct.
(bell ringing)
Dude.
Yeah, you're two for two.
So it was Mother's Day and we, it was accidental,
we just like showed up and we met each other.
We didn't even notice that we were wearing matching outfits,
and then we bumped into somebody walking down the street
and they were like, oh, you're matching outfits.
And we were like, we are?
And so then we've decided to take a picture.
Oh, that's so sweet.
My daughter kicked me in the shins this morning.
Okay.
It's the truth.
Next fun fact.
Okay, can write with her feet.
I'm going to Sarah.
(bell ringing)
Three for three.
Dudes!
I'm so excited.
See this is how I am with my girlfriends,
I call them dudes.
We were in grade six, I think,
and I was passing notes in class and getting in trouble,
and so then I just wrote the note under the desk
'cause I, I mean you can imagine
have very unattractive long toes, if that's possible.
But how like inventive, okay.
Walks a cat outside in a cat pack.
I'm going Roan.
Oh yeah.
(bell ringing)
Okay, so I got it before we went into lockdown
and it was kind of like a joke,
like I bought it for myself being like,
I'd like to take Gremlin, my cat out for walks
and that was like once or twice,
and then lockdown hits and I have nothing to do
but take my cat out for walks in a backpack.
And now I'm known as the lady
who walks around my neighborhood
with the yellow cat backpack.
(audience laughing)
All right.
The last fact is really good at limbo,
I'm going Sarah with this one.
Okay, so interestingly enough,
you are right and also it's wrong too.
We both have this crazy,
like it was so weird in the show,
we sort of found that we have all these similar mannerisms
and we kind of both love to dance,
and have a lot of similar interests,
but we both have our like our secret kind of superpower
is limbo for both of us.
Oh wow, that's low.
We got pretty low.
I honestly, I think Sarah was better at it than I was.
I think like I fell,
I don't know if you can kind of see it at the end there,
but I like fall kind of like onto my, onto all fours,
and she like kept going, like she was on it.
Yeah, Sarah, you're like full bend.
I don't know when I'm going to learn my lesson,
this is something that I love to do,
and I've always loved to do but,
it's turned into a foot ankle injury situation,
and I've had to go to the doctor twice now
and they said so how did you do this?
And I'm like, limbo again.
Well, you know, listen,
you've got writing to do with those feet,
you've got paddle boarding and crabs to catch,
so just take care of that body of yours,
'Cause it seems like you know how to embrace life
and have a good time,
and I just want to thank you Sarah and Roan
so much for joining me and giving us all a taste of
what it's like to have the female experience
and all the friendship that goes with it,
and so thank you,
I just am such a "Firefly Lane" fan.
Thank you ladies so much.
And of course, "Eat Wheaties!"
will be in theater and demand.
This Friday, April 30th is when it drops,
so check that out and "Firefly Lane"
if you haven't already seen it,
it was number one on Netflix, but it's still on Netflix,
so thank you so much for coming today.
I really, really appreciate it.
(upbeat music)